[Musique]
étranger
nous prévoyons de faire une série de trois
missions d'un an où nous sélectionnons
des équipages qui sont des astronautes blancs et ils
vivront ici dans Mars June
Alpha et ils seront isolés et
confinés pour cela  année et ils
mèneront des activités similaires à ce que
nous attendons d'eux sur une
surface de marais
[Musique]
merci
vous êtes installé ici
et vous voulez voir la base médicale
[Musique]
l'habitat a été imprimé en 3D c'est un
des technologies que la NASA
considère comme un potentiel pour construire des habitats sur
d'autres surfaces planétaires ou lunaires
étrangères
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique]
donc ceci est une serre
sur la surface de Mars ceci est une pile à combustible
ceci est une station météo
ceci  est un panneau solaire
et ce ne sont que différents éléments
que nous avons sur la surface de Mars qui
entreront en jeu au fur et à mesure que l'équipage fait
sa chronologie et effectue différentes opérations de
maintenance et activités que nous
attendons via Mars
[Music]
merci